hello everyone uh another huge
acquisition um what a what a start to
gaming news for 2022 off to a roaring
start so if you missed the news this
morning bungie is joining playstation
but there are a few things that i wanted
to talk about because i'm seeing people
just say some stuff that is incorrect um
potentially
not with the full information they read
a tweet and ran with it or whatever so
let's cover the story first also
apologies about my webcam i'm in a hotel
room
um so this is from the playstation blog
january 31 2022 bungie is joining
playstation
legendary developer to join playstation
as an independent multi-platform studio
and publisher for reference if you don't
know i do work with sony currently at
santa monica studio uh we sometimes or i
sometimes have heard about acquisitions
before they're announced definitely did
not know about this one
uh so this is written by jim ryan
president and ceo of sony interactive
entertainment and says today i am happy
to announce bungie will be joining the
playstation family first off i want to
be very clear to the community that
bungie will remain an independent and
multi-platform studio and publisher that
is the thing that is clear in this that
i think some other outlets haven't
covered um we'll remain an independent
and multi-platform studio and publisher
um but we'll get into what that means
i've spent a lot of time with pete
parsons jason jones and the bungee
management team to develop the right
relationships where they will be fully
backed and supported by sony interactive
entertainment and unable to do what they
do best build incredible worlds that
captivate millions of people uh goes on
to say bungie's world-class expertise in
multi-platform development and live game
service
also a key will help us deliver on our
vision of expanding playstation to
hundreds of millions of gamers bungie is
a great innovator and has developed
incredible proprietary tools that will
help playstation studios achieve new
heights under herman hall's leadership
to add more context to this one
specifically um here is an article from
games industry.biz it says playstation
bungie deal is about multi-platform live
service games sony interactive
entertainment head jim ryan says we
should expect more acquisitions
and this is something that like is
pretty clear to me across the board uh
and i
am saying this
very much as an independent i do not
know anything about this that you don't
know where santa monica is concerned but
uh
there have been teams within playstation
that have been hiring for multiplayer um
insomniac is one of those teams this is
publicly available information obviously
suck a punch for the first time ever
made a multiplayer mode it seems to be
something that sony's progressively
getting more interested in so
this says playstation's acquisition of
bungie may not result in exclusive ps5
games and i really don't think it will
but it will allow the platform hauler to
significant significantly accelerate its
ability to make online live service
games across different platforms which
is part of what they kind of spoke about
in the announcement is that they are
interested in um bungie's technology i
think um that's part of that acquisition
is the technology it's not just about
making destiny this is a bit of a bigger
play than that
uh in an interview with games
industry.biz sony interactive
entertainment ceo jim ryan says the
destiny 2 and future bungee games will
continue to be published on other
platforms including rival consoles the
advantages bungie offers sony in its
ability to make huge multi-platform live
service online games which is something
the wider organization is eager to learn
from he continues pete and i have spent
a long time talking and we were struck
by how similarly we see the world and
just how complementary our two
organizations are we're like two pieces
of a jigsaw that can slot together they
make massive immersive games that have
no end whereas playstation strength as
you know is the single player is in the
single player sorry narrative rich
stories our studios make those games and
they are some of the best games you'll
find anywhere i agree
i've been on record talking about
increasing the size of the playstation
community and expanding beyond our
historic console heartland this can take
many forms and definitely one of the
main ones is the ability for the
wonderful games that we've been making
over the past 25 years to be enjoyed in
different places and played in different
ways we are starting to go
multi-platform you've seen that you have
an aggressive roadmap with live service
and the opportunity to work with and
particularly learn from the brilliant
and talented people from bungie that is
going to considerably accelerate the
journey we find ourselves on um
and this is i think the the biggest
thing an aggressive road map with live
services um unsurprising considering the
monetization though not something that i
love to hear personally
um philosophically this isn't about
pulling things into the playstation
world it's about building huge and
wonderful new worlds together
on the bungee side pete parsons also
spoke to them
about
sony offering the ability to accelerate
its own plans which includes a prospect
of taking its ip to new entertainment
mediums such as film and tv which of
course we've already seen with uh ghost
tsushima and with uncharted so that's
also unsurprising sony obviously a
massive uh film studio as well
which is kind of exciting for video
games maybe someone figured out how to
do it right
so
yeah i feel like this is just extra
detail into why sony is interested in
this one specifically it's not about
destiny it's about what bungie can do
and how they might be able to help other
studios with some cross studio
initiatives basically okay so that's
that part of it mostly covered that i
feel like people are very confused about
um just to go back to the original
article and then pete parsons ceo of
bungie said we believe games have
limitless potential and that to do
anything worthwhile in entertainment we
must bet on our vision on our studio and
on our incredible team of trusted
creators who build unforgettable worlds
that truly matter to people in sony we
have found a partner who unconditionally
supports us in all we are and who we
want and who wants to accelerate our
vision to create generation spanning
entertainment all while preserving the
creative independence again i think it's
a really big part of this
that beats in bungie's heart
like us sony believes that game worlds
are only the beginning of what our ips
can become together we share a dream of
creating fast creating and fostering
iconic franchises that unite friends
around the world families across
generations and fans across multiple
platforms and entertainment mediums
today bungie begins our journey to
become a global multimedia entertainment
company
this is especially interesting because
bungie was previously owned by
activision or at least how to deal with
activision um so obviously you go back
far enough bungie is halo so they were
microsoft and then uh and i believe the
original halo was actually going to come
out on playstation as well but the
acquisition made it an xbox exclusive
and then obviously went to make destiny
and then joined activision
and then left activision basically
alluding to the fact that they weren't
happy with the deal under activision
they didn't like working with activision
and they said how excited they were to
go back to being independent um and now
they join playstation but they are still
framing themselves as being independent
here so it says since taking flight in
1991 bungie has always charted the
future with our own star map a part that
is driven by our people and for our
community we are continuing that journey
with new worlds in development and we
can't wait to share them with you with
sony the potential for our universes is
unlimited our future games which means
money for the record means sony has a
lot of money and they do they still have
a massive market share
um or at least revenue share our future
games will take bold steps into
unexplored spaces for bungie continue to
push the boundaries of what is possible
and will always be built on a foundation
of creating meaning meaningful lifelong
friendships and memories we remain in
charge of our destiny nice
we will continue to independently
publish and creatively develop our games
so they still have creative freedom and
i imagine that this was very important
to bungie
we will continue to drive one unified
bungie community our games will continue
to be wherever our community is where
our community is sorry wherever they
choose to play with sony support the
most immediate change you will see is an
acceleration and hiring talent across
the entire studio to support our
ambitious vision if this speaks to you
you want to help us put a dent in the
universe we are hiring across all
disciplines for destiny 2 and all new
worlds beyond so if we click on the
bungie article we'll just jump over to
this one here
this is a post from 2019 about them
leaving activision
uh which says when we first launched our
partnership with activision in 2010 the
gaming industry was in a pretty
different place as an independent studio
setting out to build a brand new
experience we wanted a partner willing
to take a big leap of faith with us we
had a vision for destiny that we
believed in but to launch a game of that
magnitude we needed the support of an
established publishing partner they
created something special etc etc
um and they thanked them but ultimately
said that they took publishing rights
back and that is staying the same that's
a part of this that i wanted to bring up
because i feel like again maybe people
are reading
uh just tweets or maybe they're seeing
this covered from
other websites and didn't actually go to
the playstation blog as the source where
it makes it sound like uh sony is
controlling our publishing rights but
that is that is not correct um they said
that they are sticking by this which
means with our remarkable destiny
community we are ready to publish on our
own and that you know that is literally
linked to that they are planning to stay
the same sony let them link that in that
article that's a pretty uh bold
suggestion
um
which is a really unique approach to
this kind of deal
uh so yeah they're hiring obviously
working on whatever their next game is
which is exciting and then just to close
out the um the full article on the
playstation vlog which by the way i love
how much detail they have in this it's
awesome three decades and counting what
makes our worlds come to life is our
community and our people in the studio
our people are the solar bungee
empowered by our people we have pushed
the boundaries of what we thought was
possible and transformed who we are as a
company more than anything sony
understands that our people and our
community are both the priority and the
heart of our success and are willing to
stand alongside us as we continue to use
our platform to drive action towards a
more welcoming and equitable world our
goal is to build a pla build a place
where the world's most creative and
talented people can come and do their
best work no matter who they are where
they are from or how they identify
that's the real dent in the universe we
want to make the one we want to last
beyond us be a part of this futuristic
cu star side
like it's a really nice thing to say and
clearly
um they have a big focus on hiring and
they needed money to be able to do it so
no doubt that this is going to be uh
financially beneficial for playstation
but i do think it is important to note
they're being
very
very explicit here which i imagine
bungie fought for um about saying that
uh bungie still has full creative
freedom and that their games will still
be available on multiple platforms which
is something that yeah i feel like
everybody's just kind of losing in this
one so it's certainly a unique
acquisition um related to that the one
thing that i think
people are you know
maybe the most um
quick to to to jump to about is the
suggestion that this is a retaliation to
microsoft buying activision blizzard
this is such a different deal um so
first these acquisitions take forever uh
it sounds like the activision blizzard
deal
uh from what i read started in november
at the very least
which is actually very short and phil is
on record saying you know we turned this
run around really quickly which is to
say
several months um a couple of months and
that is really fast but that is easier
to do when activision blizzard is in a
position of crisis that clearly needed
help because of the lawsuits because of
the terrible pr right now their stales
are
stagnant i feel like that word is a lot
more negative than i intend to convey it
i mean they also have like blizzard
hasn't released a game since overwatch
like they were in a position
where i imagine they were looking to get
bought uh it was beneficial for them to
move quickly i imagine this deal
just a guess but i would have guessed
over a year
um i would think that
bungie was also looking for it uh both
of these don't look to me as though the
execs walked into bungie or walked into
activision blizzard it looks to me the
other way around potentially
bungie was looking to get quiet again
but was very very particular about how
they wanted their relationship to be um
and
i i think this would have taken forever
the wording that you need even in those
legal contracts can take months to iron
out there is no universe in which this
happened in two weeks it is just
it's just not possible um you don't
casually spend i think this deal was
three billion
um just as a response and it's also not
a response it's like i said such a
different publishing deal it's so
different um the two things like are
basically not related they just happen
to drop kind of nearby one another
like whistleblowers told sony but why
would they do this like they wouldn't
it just i just don't buy it like maybe
maybe sony knew ahead of time about
microsoft and active vision blizzard so
they went for bungie like that's such a
weird path to take you know i just i
don't feel like that makes any sense it
also just again i think this deal
especially is really unique and very
very complicated and would have been
really really hard for the lawyers to
hash out and i respect the hell out of
bungie for fighting for their creative
freedom here um this is a pretty small
acquisition in the grand scheme of
things especially when you consider
activision blizzard was 68 billion
dollars this is a smaller one but
playstation has been acquiring a lot of
studios and everyone's talking about
like what's next who's gonna be next
like this this keeps happening more and
more
and i feel like what we're seeing is
yeah playstation acquiring a lot of
smaller studios across
the way like uh uh
blue point and house mark um a lot of
smaller
you know partnerships um where microsoft
was doing obviously basically publishers
um
and yeah i think it's i hope that not
everybody gets bought up i don't want to
see that i don't want to see a future
where that happens i think bungie makes
perfect sense they are a really big
studio they are functioning in a triple
a space it's almost weird that they were
indie
um
i don't want to see everyone get
purchased though i hope that you know we
have some third-party publishers still
existing
um there's a lot of creativity that you
can be offered you know not partnering
with one of these big publishers or big
platforms
but maybe the destiny deal sorry the
bungee deal is one that will lead to
that being like slightly healthier in
the long run where maybe people do have
a lot more creative freedom so
congrats to bungie welcome to
playstation uh that is it for me today
everyone um just wanted to
clear some of that stuff up so
yeah thanks for watching let me know
what you think it's a
truly a wild start to 2022.